I checked out from news over the weekend,
so when I started reviewing events from the
g 20 in Japan, I had a ton of catching up
to do.
We had Trump stepping into North Korea.
We had world leaders, uh, visibly cringing
as Ivanka Trump tried to talk to them about
policy, which I'll get to.
And then we also had Donald Trump being asked
about busing and liberalism and being so clueless
that he simply stated that buses are a primary
way of getting people to school.
This is one of those things that is funny
in a superficial sense, but it's so, so tragic.
And I guess I was laughing in order to not
cry because it is the latest world embarrassment.
Thanks to President Donald Trump.
Trump was first asked about busing as racial
integration policy.
There's a big history of this in the United
States.
So when we talk about busing in politics,
we're not talking literally about, do you
like buses versus vans, cars or bikes for
getting kids to school.
Um, we're talking about busing programs that
date back to the 1970s.
The whole point of it was to desegregate classrooms
to have more racially diverse schools.
It's very controversial.
There are many arguments to be had about it.
The reason that it's back in the news is that,
uh, in debate one night, two last week on
the democratic side, when Kamala Harris called
out Joe Biden during that debate, it was related
to Joe Biden's policy on race related issues,
which includes that Joe Biden opposed federally
required busing policy and Donald Trump was
asked about it and the guy is just so clueless
about this that you can see how confused he
is and eventually he simply sort of white
flags and says buses have been a primary way
of getting children to school.
Clearly having no idea what Kristen Welker
from NBC news is asking him about.
And yeah, it's as embarrassing and cringeworthy
as it sounds.
Let's look at it together.
Thank you.
I have a question about the border, but I
just wanted to follow up quickly on the question
about busing.
Do you see it as a viable way of integrating
schools?
Does that relate to the policy that you're
sheltering or they've done for a long period
of time?
I mean, you know, there, there aren't that
many ways you're going to get people to schools.
So this is something that's been done.
In some cases it's been done with a hammer
on set of a velvet love and you know, that's
part of it.
But this has been certainly a thing that's
been used over there.
I think if if, uh, vice president Biden had
answered the question somewhat differently,
it would have been a lot, it would have been
a different result because they really did,
uh, hit him hard on that one.
So, uh, but it is certainly a, a primary method
of getting people to schools.
And is it, does it relate to the policy that
you're going to unveil that you just floated?
It relates to everything we're doing.
Uh, and you'll be hearing about it and over
the next couple of months,
this is like being asked about the nuclear
triad and saying, well, listen, triad refers
to three and that's a bigger number than two.
So that's really something we have to contend
with.
I mean, it's just idiocy.
This is a non-answer and this is what the
president of the United States believes qualifies
as a political answer to the question.
Then once again, during the same press conference,
Donald Trump was asked about Vladimir Putin's
recent comments that western style liberalism
is obsolete and Trump is so ignorant that
he thought that liberalism meant those lefties
on the California coast, like in San Francisco
and Los Angeles.
He thought that liberalism meant, I guess
progressivism when, what we're talking about
here is small l liberalism, which includes
the sort of broader Pulisic political philosophy
of the West that includes individual rights
and capitalism and freedom of speech and freedom
of religion.
It applies to most Western democracies even
though it looks different in Germany and in
the UK and in the United States for example.
And those are all small l liberalism.
Trump thinks they're asking about like Bernie
Sanders and he criticizes Los Angeles in San
Francisco.
I can't believe that he's significant, but
he is
his, his comments to the Financial Times right
before arriving here was that western style
liberalism is obsolete.
I know you probably haven't read it, read
it, but again, he may feel that way.
I mean, he sees what's going on.
And, uh, I guess if you look at what's happening
in Los Angeles where, uh, it's so sad to look
and what's happening in San Francisco and
a couple of other cities which are, uh, run,
uh, by an extraordinary group of liberal people.
I don't know what they're thinking, but he
does see things that are happening in the
United States that, uh, would, would probably
preclude him from saying how wonderful it
is.
At the same time, he congratulated me as every
other, every other leader of every country
did for what we've done economically because
we've probably have the strongest economy
we've ever had.
And that's a real positive.
But, uh, I'm very embarrassed by what I see
in some of our cities where the politicians
are either afraid to do something about it
or they think it's votes or I don't know what
Peter, I don't know what they're thinking.
But when you look at Los Angeles, uh, when
you look at San Francisco, when you look at
some of the other cities, and not a lot, not
a lot, but you don't want it to spread.
And, uh, at a certain point I think the federal
government may be has to get involved.
We can't let that continue to happen to our
citizens.
This
is breathtaking.
I mean breathtaking ignorance and Trump puts
the cherry on top with his own closing on
this by saying that he likes the dictators
of the world better than he likes our western
allies.
This has nothing to do with the question.
It has nothing to do with what Vladimir Putin
is talking about.
Understand Putin was talking about our system
of government.
Putin was not talking about American prevet,
progressivism and hipsters in San Francisco.
Understand the level of disconnect here.
Donald Trump thinks that this press conference
was about his general opinion of kids getting
to school on school buses and he believes
Vladimir Putin criticized American progressivism
like San Francisco politics.
In reality, Trump was asked about busing policy
for racial integration and the idea that small
l liberalism as a political philosophy has
become a sort of obsolete in 2019.
Trump doesn't even know what he was asked
about on with many other presidents.
I mean, I'm actually struggling to even talk
about this with somebody like George W. Bush.
Okay.
Whose policies I completely disagreed with.
You would actually be analyzing what Bush
said, mostly along the lines of whether, whether
whether you agree with it and whether we believe
that he is reaching the correct or incorrect
conclusions on the basis of the facts that
are out there.
Donald Trump doesn't know what he was asked
about.
Okay.
Donald Trump answered questions that were
not asked.
It is a total joke of a presidency and unfortunately
too many are equally ignorant here.
They also don't know what were the questions
actually about small l liberalism and busing
for racial integration.
Some of them don't know what it was about.
Some of them also don't know.
So they came away from this thinking, Trump's
on it.
Trump knows what he's talking about.
We are the laughingstock of the world and
that's actually the theme of the next story
as well.
A lot of laughing stock over
the weekend.